three cancer survivors are suing the
Cleveland area fertility clinic
that accidentally destroyed more than
4,000 stored embryos and eggs they
announced this lawsuit yesterday all
three women said they went through
painful fertility treatments and the
clinic well just betrayed their trust
this is the latest in a series of
lawsuits against this clinic our dr.
taryn arul has been following the story
and joins us at the table Tara good
morning good morning Gail roughly 950
families are believed to be impacted by
last month's storage tank failure now
there are calls to strengthen
regulations on an industry that many
Americans depend on to protect their
eggs losing my fertility was not an
option for me in an emotional press
conference the cancer survivors told
similar and painful stories I risked my
life and delayed my chemotherapy
treatments because hiring a family was
so important to me Rachael Mel says when
she learned her eggs were gone it was
like a punch to the gut because of the
carelessness of uhf university hospitals
I have now lost all hopes of ever having
biological children the new lawsuit
alleges University Hospitals did not
notify its clients or double-check to
make sure its local and remote
monitoring systems were functional
despite being aware of issues with the
liquid nitrogen storage tank in the
weeks preceding last month's malfunction
in a letter to patients last week
University Hospitals admitted the tank
in question needed preventive
maintenance prior to the March 3rd
incident the tanks that protect embryos
are often exempt from government
oversight but there are proposals in the
works for new regulations Ohio State
Senator Joe Schiavoni is in the early
stages of crafting regulatory
legislation with fellow lawmakers if
something goes wrong with the chemical
makeup of this tank then there should be
a trigger
there should be alarm and there needs to
be somebody there that could remedy the
situation immediately but for some the
suggested regulations have come too late
you H must be held accountable for
shattering our dreams and for forever
altering the courses of each of our
lives University Hospitals responded to
yesterday's
press conference in a statement saying
we watched three women share their
stories of the loss they suffered we are
profoundly sorry for their loss and are
committed to helping make sure this
never happens again anywhere a bit
sorry's little consolation to those
women that was your only hope even if
they win I mean they didn't get the
family but have been hoping for right
they said they were robbed of their
health they were robbed of so much and
now their future you know it's just so
devastating hearts just go out to them
Tara thank you thank you